- Il est rendu trop long,
tu vas avoir un collier qui
va aller jusqu'à tes orteils?- i
pour Julie Arbour et sa fille.
Julie est mère monoparentale
et habite à Sainte-Thérèse,
au nord de Montréal.
Représentante pour un courtier
en alimentation, elle parcourt(,
en voiture. La hausse du prix
de l'essence lui coûte 100 $
de plus par mois.
JULIE ARBOUR
- Dans ma voiture, actuellement,
ça me dit que je peux faire
432 km de route, environ
un presque 70 $ d'essence.
Ce soir, quand maman elle
arrive, on se dépêche pour aller
au cours.
- Elle a laissé Anaïs à l'école,
son stress face à l'inflation.
Julie doit maintenant tout
calculer pour ne pas s'endetter.
- C'est de la gymnastique,
beaucoup, beaucoup, beaucoup
de gymnastique budgétaire.
- Par son métier, elle constate
à quel point le prix des
aliments a explosé lui aussi.
- Notammandes,
l'augmentation a été flagrante.
Par exemple, on passe
rammes à 200 grammes
avec une augmentation de 3 $
pour le même produit.
- Encore là, pour elle,
c'est un autre 100 $ de plus
à payer chaque mois.
- Et ça,picerie
de base. Il n'y a pas
de gâteries à faire
à travers ça, là.
- Est-ce qu'il reste de la place
pour les
- De moins en moins.
Il faut que j'explique
à mon enfant qu'il y a des choix
également à faire.
ie Lavallée aide les
citoyens comme Julie aux prises
avec un casse-tête financier.
Chaque semaine, cet hiver, une
vingtaine de nouveaux ménages
des Basses-Laurentides
lui demandent conseil.
NATHALIE LAVALLÉE,
intervenante en consommation
- On note que de plus en plus
de familles, de travailleurs
nous appellent. On sent une plus
grande détresse, puis il y a
toujours eu nos populations
vulnérables qu'on connaît,
mais ça touche Monsieur,
Madame Tout-le-monde maintenant.
Les gens ont vraiment
plus de difficulté à combler
leurs besoins de base.
- Elle estime qu'une famille
doit maintenant gagner 80 000 $
brut par année pour éviter
les tracas de l'en
Le revenu moyen des ménages
québécois est d'environ
85 000 $.
- Avec deux enfants en bas âge
actuellement, je pense
qu'un ménage en bas de 80 000
par année, et si on parle
d'un logement très raisonnable,
ça serait la limite, là,
parce qu'avec l'explosion
des coûts, avec l'explosion des
coûts au niveau des hypothèques
là, ça se corse!- C'est - C'est?
- Divisé.
- (ensemble): Divisé!
(rires)
- Et ça se corse même pour ceux,
comme la famille Fauteux, qui
font partie d'une classe moyenne
un peu mieux nantie.
Joanie egnent
ensemble, actuellement,
92 000 $ par année. Lui est
militaire et fait l'aller-retour
Mirabel-Montréal chaque jour
de semaine.JOLAN FAUTEUX
- Il y a un an, là, remplir
ma voiture pour une semaine,
ça me coûtait à peu près
45-50 $, puis là,
c'est plus autour du 90.
JOANIE SIMARD
- Pour réduire n5
d'épicerie le plus possible,
on va aller plus vers le cannage
on faire de la conservation.
On va plus cuisiner en gros,
puis malgré ça, ça coûte plus
que 100 $ la différence!
- Joanie est responsable du
budget et elle le tient serré.
- Nos dépenses personnelles,
on est rendus à 20 $ chaque
par semaine.
Ça y va!
- Ils réussissent encore
à épargner un peu,
mais trois fois moins qu'avant.
L'inflation et l'explosion
des prixt
en train de briser leur rêve :
celui de quitter leur 5 et demi
pour acheter une petite maison
dans les Laurentides.
- On peut de moins en moins
surenchérir sur le
fait que là, on se dit que
finalement, peut-être que
le rêve d'être propriétaires
n'est plus à la portée des gens
de la cl
À partir du moment où t'as
frappé ta limite d'augmenter
tes revenus, que t'as dégraissé
ton cochon à ton maximum,
puis que là, tu te dis : Là,
je n'ai plus rien! Je n'ai plus
de loisirs, je n'ai plus
d'épargne, je n'ai plus... Je
n'ai plus le droit de rê
bien. qu'est-ce qu'on fait?
- Ils ont de grandes attentes
envers le budget du Québec,
mardi, et espèrent tous
des mesures à long terme
plutôt qu'un chèque unique.
- Un registre public des loyers,
comme ça les propriétaires
vont pouvoir arrêter d'augmenter
- Offrir des façons de consommer
autrement. Tu sais, par exemple,
moi, je vais dans une maison
de la famille, bien, je peuxs a,
c'est gratuit.
- Peut-être d'augmenter
le taux du salaire minimum
pour permettre aux gens d'avoir.
- Qu'est-ce que vous aimeriez
entendre de ce budget-là?
- Un miracle!
(rire)- Un peu d'ironie, et surt
l'espoir d'un répit.
Ici Jean-Sébastien Cloutier,
Radio-Canada, Mir